see of Ramsey solutions Anya is with us
hey Anya how are you better than I
deserve David how are you doing better
than I deserve welcome welcome thank you
good to have you so where do you live I
live in Virginia Beach Virginia oh very
cool well welcome to Nashville and here
to do your debt free scream yes sir
way to go how much have you paid off I
paid off eighteen thousand dollars in
five months eighteen thousand and five
months yes sir and making what kind of
money I started out with making twenty
nine hundred and then I dropped down to
sixteen hundred twenty-nine hundred a
month a month yeah so 36 thousand a year
and now you're down to sixteen hundred a
month which is about $17,000 a year what
do you do I am in the military Navy
bringe
okay all right and so entry level
obviously yes and but I think but the
sixteen hundred allows they still
furnish housing and food and everything
at that yes okay what are you doing the
Navy
I am Aviation both made handlers so I
work with the planes I land them and
secure them oh very cool
Wow awesome thank you for your service
appreciate it yeah very nice
what made you odd desire to go into that
I wanted to see the world and I also
wanted to get my college education paid
for so and it's a great experience to be
in the military taught me a lot so yeah
I'm thankful for that absolutely very
cool so what kind of debt was the
eighteen thousand it was my brand-new
car that I bought before I read your
book like that okay and so did you sell
it or just pay it off I paid it off okay
so you paid off eighteen thousand
dollars in five months
that's more than you made during that
period of time so how did you do that I
worked a lot of part-time jobs so I did
a lot of dog-sitting house-sitting I
worked for several cleaning companies at
the same time as well so I worked a lot
of hours to be able to pay it off so
sure you're allowed to do side jobs
while you're in the Navy correct
oh wow okay very cool so your income
during that period of time was much
higher than your stated salary that you
just gave me yes okay very good
the 29 included my part-time jobs I see
okay all right Wow
well you got it in gear kiddo way to go
excellent so what got you started on
this journey five months ago my parents
did actually my mom she called me like
hey like there's this class Financial
Peace University and when I heard about
it I thought she was more like a college
class if you know it's University so I
was like no mom I don't really want to
do it but mom was really persistent and
she's like okay we'll pay for it will
you go and I went to your Financial
Peace University class and I loved it
like it was so encouraging and having
the other people with me really
motivated me to get this done and I'm
super excited how old are you I am 22
years old excellent way to go and your
mom came with you today to be your
cheerleader she did so did my dad I
gotta be really proud of you I hope so
well they came all the way to Nashville
to watch you do it that freeze cream I
think they are excellent job so what do
you tell other 22 year olds out there
that that they have to do if they want
to get out of debt what is the secret oh
it's not so much as a secret as I had to
learn to be okay with not getting
invited out with friends it was really
difficult to do this debt-free gazelle
intensity sort of thing that I was
trying to do because that meant like no
going out to eat no social gatherings
pretty much and it was really that's why
I really had to do I had to you didn't
have time to go out to eat oh you were
walking it's true but I still tried I
still wanted to get invited you know
it's really difficult - how much was
your composition I think they're my
payments were I mean my original payment
was to 239 God or you paid a bunch extra
though yeah about a thousand to 2,000
some months so I try to put as much as I
could into it so any little
cash left over I dumped it all into my
car way to go very good job on you
excellent excellent job all right
on you from Virginia Beach serving us in
the Navy America here she is 22 years
old $18,000 paid off in five months
making thirty six thousand seventeen
thousand somewhere in that range with
all those extra jobs count it down
let's hear a deck free scream three two
one guys excellent excellent excellent
that is how it's done